hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong my name is mark
ellis i am joined as always by my
esteemed co-host jacqueline coley and
jacqueline when you think about this
time of year some people go pumpkin
spice latte which i still have never
tried but i gotta say i'm a little
curious for whatever reason this is the
first year that i've actually wanted to
try what is happening to me um you're
getting older and you're just embracing
like your old man-isms
i mean look
i will say this i don't see you having
like a midlife crisis but i could very
much see you getting into like dad gear
without having children like you're
already you're already embracing
sometimes the dad jokes
you you definitely enjoy sports puns
better than most people
psl is like
that's the extension i hate pumpkin
spice latte if they ever made a sweet
potato latte i'd be all about that but i
am more of an eggnog girl
okay so we got one more
like holiday we got another half holiday
season to go to
massage your thirst and appetite
but a lot of people do there's a raging
debate about candy corn right now and of
course it is halloween i am pro candy
corn for what it's worth and i'm also
very pro this franchise that we are
going to talk about today yep we're
talking about an entire franchise and
that would be
scream it started back in the mid 90s
and it just turned the horror world on
its ear the meta examination within a
very fun whodunit sort of movie slasher
film context directed by wes craven is
celebrating its 25th anniversary this
year we were so young there's a 4k of
the film coming out soon and in january
get this kid scream 5 is going to be
released in theaters around the world
most of the original cast coming back at
least the people that are still um live
in the movie that didn't die off in the
movie are coming back for scream five we
hope and it's just gonna be a fun time
breaking this all down today because the
first two films certified fresh no
problem there scream three
all the way down to rotten at forty
percent scream four
rebounded for the most part it got back
to fresh barely at sixty percent so
we're gonna be talking about what we
love what we don't like and what we
think rotten tomatoes might be wrong
about with these four screen movies that
we have gotten a chance to see and our
guest today is a returning favorite
friend of the show needs no introduction
mainly because he can tell me what to do
and so i'm going to give him a very good
one that would be the rotten tomatoes
editor-in-chief he's a horror enthusiast
and
a scream stan
joel mears is back on the show joel i
say tomato you say tomato
let's not call the whole thing off
because we're talking about scream
absolutely nice to be here mock hi
jacqueline how you doing hi
this is going to be fun because joel has
i've known joel uh for years now and i
think probably the first time we met he
did profess his love of scream but joel
you also have some hot takes within the
world of scream so what exactly
is rotten tomatoes again you're the
editor-in-chief of rotten tomatoes what
what is right tomatoes wrong about when
it comes to this franchise it always
puts me in a tricky position you know
and actually my first day at rotten
tomatoes one of the things they do is
ask you for your five favorite films
which is a column that we do it's sort
of a way of introduction and scream was
number one on my list so i think along
with our good friend perry nemeroff
we are potentially some of the biggest
screen stands out there so i think that
rotten tomatoes is generally wrong-ish
about the scream franchise i think they
get
some of it right in terms of the overall
trajectory but i quibble with the
numbers themselves so i do believe
myself and most fans would say one and
two are the best films and deserving of
their certified first status but i think
they could be a tad higher i think
scream is certified fresh at 79
i think a horror classic of this ilk
should at least be in the 90s uh then
screen four three dripping down to
rotten i disagree with completely i
think it should be at least fresh i
think it's an underrated gem and we can
get into that a bit and scream four
sixty percent i'm pretty fine with
it's a journey it's a journey um i'm
always changing my opinion because these
movies i rewatch probably constantly
i've probably seen screen one
upwards of 40 times screen two upwards
of 50 and the others sort of in the 20s
and every time i have a different
experience and sort of changed my mind
so i have been warning to scream for in
the last couple of years in a way that i
didn't love it when it first came out
yeah i remember feeling the same way
when scream four first came out and i
was like yeah right it was nice to see
everybody again but 40 times for that
first one it may change for you joel it
never changes for tatum unfortunately
jacqueline
you now get the i i would say this is
actually going to be a fun one to do a
synopsis for because sometimes we got
the movies on here and it's like what do
i talk about what do i leave out but
scream i mean come on you get to talk
about ghost face and who he's killing
yeah actually and actually i was just
gonna say this mark i have been told
that i don't get the duties today
as a sort of tribute to the s scream
aficionado that he is
and also because i did not study to do
that because i knew i didn't think i was
like he did homework i didn't do
no it said that you were doing it we all
read our agendas here don't worry we've
read the spreadsheet we know what's
going on i've been studying
studying for this exam since i was about
12 years old so
um
so the screen franchise is a horror
slash of a franchise that centers on
three characters essentially so there is
gail weathers played by courtney cox
she's an ambitious uh tv uh host uh news
reporter with uh likes to change her
hairstyles from time to time and then we
have dewey reilly played by david
arquette who is the deputy sheriff of
woodsboro the local town and sort of
gets a career boost as the career as the
movies go on and sydney prescott who was
our final girl played by the great nev
campbell who was coming out of party at
five when the first movie came out um
she is variously a high school student a
college student uh a
therapist and then a professional victim
i guess in number four and so
essentially what happens with each film
is that a group they get attacked by
someone in the ghost face mask
we wonder who it is and why they're
doing it the people around them and
their lives get attacked uh killed
usually and these three survive all the
way through uh and the big question is
who and why is committing these uh these
brutal murders which usually involve
some form of technology at the beginning
few films it was a phone call a few
quizzes if you get it wrong you die uh
most famously in the opening scene with
drew barrymore as casey becker um and
then the interesting thing is that the
films really do interesting things with
the horror genre and the settings the
first one is kind of a play on halloween
meets scooby-doo and comments on the
slasher genre it's very meta everyone
understands what they're doing they're
in a horror movie two is sort of your
college campus and it looks at the idea
of fame and violence three is set in
hollywood uh they're making the stab
movies which is a series based on the
original woodsboro murders which
happened in screen one so it gets very
very meta uh and then four is kind of a
reboot and uh well it's definitely it's
kind of your force awakens old gen new
gen uh with a twist um and it comments
on the nature of reboot so there are
rules for sequels trilogy closers which
don't end up being trilogy closers and
reboots and there's lots of blood um
kevin uh williamson wrote directed the
first few uh didn't direct them sorry
where's craven came in directed them uh
all four so i guess that's it and we're
gearing up for number five and uh dewey
gail and sydney are back this is
we should have the guests do the
synopsis every time jack when it takes
the work off of our plate and joel is
one for one as far as guests coming in
here and telling us what the hell we're
talking about that was delightful joel
and but i'm not letting you off the hook
yet because you did mention scream three
takes place in hollywood and i am gonna
make you defend that i want i want more
insight into your opinion as to why
rotten tomatoes is wrong about that but
before we get there let's bring in
perducy lucy let's make this a party
right
he's here are you a are you a scream
queen hell to the no no
um i watched it when did it come when
did the first one come out 1996.
i probably i didn't see it in theaters i
was six years old but i probably saw it
like
two years later at a slumber party and
it effed
me up in the brain uh i can't do horror
um
and
all i remember is the end scene where
the guys are like stabbing like uh skeet
ulrich and matthew lillard are like
aren't they like stabbing each other or
something they're like in the kitchen
and bleeding yeah that scene is seared
into adolescent lucy's brain and
sometimes when i lay awake at night
that's what i see all right we gotta get
lucy
you know the 4k is coming out soon i'm
sure that we have some connections we
can get it to you and you need to give
this another chance because joel
jacqueline and i are clearly fans of the
franchise and even if we have quibbles
with specific movies within said
franchise it is just a fun one to
celebrate especially around this time of
year so joel what is it about scream
three the movie that gets panned in the
franchise more than any it's 40 rotten
that rotten tomatoes got wrong well you
know i think the critics who
reviewed the film at the time uh were
very quick to dismiss it as not
particularly scary and having fallen on
some of the tropes that the first two
films kind of skewered and parodied um
but i think what they missed was that it
was actually making
a super interesting comment about the
nature of hollywood um and i think this
is a film hey i just think it's fun so
you've got to take it as a comedy right
so i don't know if we're getting two in
the weeds before we hear from the
critics in two minutes with tim that's
me the editor-in-chief saying
subtle subtle there jim tim's waiting in
the wings somewhere but those critics i
think they missed the point that this
was leaning very much into the comedy
over the horror which would be this sort
of establishment franchise is a nice
blend and they did that partly because
um the columbine murders had happened
recently they had to redirect the entire
film to get away from sort of high
school student violence um but i think
it really works as a comedy and we can
get into a bit more in a bit but i love
parker posey as uh jennifer jolie
cleverley um who plays the gayle
weathers character in the step franchise
um and it's being reassessed in the
light of the metoo movement because if
you watch this film again it is
essentially about a woman who is used
and abused by hollywood that's sydney
prescott's mother um
uh by a character played by lance
hendrickson who was essentially a
stand-in for harvey weinstein in the
movie that was ultimately ep or produced
by harvey weinstein so it's actually a
really interesting metacommentary on
what hollywood does to people in the
ultimate trauma which actually then
triggers the beginning of the original
film so i think it's got lightness and
fun and it's really well directed and
executed it's silly at times but then
there's this really dark interesting
underlying message that sort of resets
the entire franchise he came to play
today jacqueline joel now
this is my
uh
wow with those bangs on there too i
think oh this is yeah
parker percy's bangs just yeah this is
perfect oh these are not the infamous uh
courtney screams
yeah this is the second time in in a
month that we've had a guest come in so
excited to talk about a movie that they
actually wore merchandise based on said
we had eric striffler with the mummy and
then we have joel mears with screen
three jacqueline coley before we get to
two minutes with tim because joel really
wants us to get there now what is your
take on the scream franchise what do you
think the rotten tomatoes tomato meter
got wrong
i think that in in truth be known i
don't think it's actually that far off i
would say that the first two i think are
judged on a
pre-elevated horror critical community
that basically were pleasantly surprised
that it was watchable had a plot and a
little bit more to say than
big boobs and dying girls you know what
i mean like like that that was where
they were at that point and now looking
at how it recontextualized the way we
view horror and how we sort of
the commercialization of that before tim
jumps out in this nest segment and calls
me wrong because people did it before
screen but screamed at it in a way that
brought in teen girls which is still to
this day the thing that does not get
talked about i remember watching
dawson's creek
on the cw and they played promotions of
scream like on the like every commercial
break because kevin williamson who did
dawson's creek also wrote scream and so
that was the thing they made this a
horror movie that just wasn't for you
know these horror head um kids it was
also something that teen girls could get
into and by the time we get to stream
screen 2 with jerry o'connell they are
leaning into that for everything that
it's worth look at how many tiger beat
um i would say frequents are in these
movies
that's an excellent point if you don't
want to wait for your life to be over
then um you should probably act on it
now especially if you're through
barrymore's character because it's not
gonna last long i
actually
feel similar to joel when it comes to
scream three because i remember seeing
it in the theater i remember having some
good scares in that movie in addition to
some laughs and so i don't think that it
belongs down there at 40 rotten i'm
gonna put it up there on a par with
scream four and i'm gonna get it too
fresh because there is a scene in
particular that still can creep me out
to this day in scream three and it's
when sydney prescott sees what she
believes is like a her the ghost of her
mom like slowly walking toward oh that
is good horror movie stuff right there
that is some goods now whatever happens
after you can debate but oh my god
that's a legit scare in a movie theater
and so and i think we can all agree that
the first scream feels like a 90 or a 95
percenter it doesn't feel like it
belongs with the c plus kids like me in
the high 70s and so now we are gonna
move on to see what the critics had to
say about scream at the time of those
movies released for our segment that we
love because we love our expert review
curation manager tim ryan at rotten
tomatoes here it is two minutes with tim
scream wasn't the first horror film to
satirize the conventions of the genre
student bodies in the evil dead movies
had it beat by a few years and abbott
costello meet frankenstein by decades
and director wes craven had previously
made his own meta slasher movie in wes
craven's new nightmare but scream's
monster success laid the groundwork for
self-aware horror to come which included
the likes of final destination to cabin
in the woods to the scary movie
franchise which took its name from the
title of scream's original script so
let's break down the franchise by the
numbers
scream is certified fresh at 79 with 75
reviews
scream 2 is certified fresh at 81 with
79 reviews scream 3 is rotten at 40 with
126 reviews and scream 4 is fresh at 60
with 187 reviews so what did the critics
have to say in a fresh review for the
original scream kevin thomas of the los
angeles times wrote that it was a bravo
provocative send-up of horror pictures
that's also scary and gruesome yet too
swift moving to lapse into morbidity
however in a rotten review of scream 3
mark caro of the chicago tribune wrote
that despite the various surprise cameos
and cute twists it takes itself too
seriously and adheres too strictly to
its formula to avoid becoming what it
parodies so that's scream let's kick it
back to jacqueline and mark two people
who know that there are certain rules
that one must abide by in order to
successfully survive a podcast back to
you folks i'm not sure tim is as big of
a fan of these movies as we are i
detected some saltiness the shade was uh
knee-deep on that one you could you
could definitely feel his uh look
accurate
assessment but heavy-handed dismissal
can we say that i think that's a fair
assessment and i look he's absolutely
right uh was craven's new nightmare i
think came out two years before screen
but it was kind of a warm-up i love that
film and it's great it's really well
done but it's not the perfect sort of uh
mechanical thing that scream is it
doesn't get everything right it's
playing with the same ideas i think it's
super scary but it's it's not quite
there i think it's it's you know those
ideas have been played with but had they
been done in this way i don't know tim
tim's meet me out back
i'm gonna have a
a little chat there between tim ryan and
joel mears and we're about to have a
little chat right now about the actual
movies themselves and what we love what
we think could have been better about
the scream franchise thus far it's time
for movie talk
[Music]
all right it is our favorite scream
movie time i can't get around i would
love to have a hot take about this joel
and jacqueline but the first scream just
does it checks every box for me i saw it
in the summer of 96 in a theater my
friends had already seen it they said
you're going to love this movie we were
down at the beach for some reason and so
we went to a movie theater and i
fell in love with it i loved the horror
i loved the humor it was the perfect
combination and joel going off what you
said about wes craven's new nightmare
she did a couple years prior it feels
like that movie had most of the
ingredients this one put them all in the
vitamix and just made the perfect
smoothie of a movie and added a lot more
humor because new nightmare is actually
the least funny freddy krueger's had
been since the original nightmare on elm
street he didn't have a lot of
one-liners like he did in freddie's dead
the final nightmare and so having that
sense of humor and the fact that it hit
me when i was in high school and i'm
watching high school kids go through all
this it just it made a perfect elixir
for me scream one by far my favorite uh
well no i'll say scream two is my
favorite overall it's favorite being the
one i like to return to the well most
frequently to watch and i think that's
primarily because for me it just has so
many sort of re-watchable set pieces in
the way that scream is kind of a perfect
film
but ultimately between that opening kill
and the first uh sort of interaction
where sydney gets her first phone call
and gets ghostface there's there's not a
huge amount of sort of bigger set pieces
that happen and i think in screen two uh
until of course the finale in the house
where traumatized lucy for many years
screen two has um
just more for me again spectacular
things i like to re-watch so you've got
the opening scene with jada pinkett
smith and omar epps which i think is
degree of difficulty to try and match
that drew barrymore scene um but do it
in a really innovative way that isn't
full of jump scares but is absolutely
traumatizing and emotionally
wrenching i think jada pinkett smith is
so good in that scene
is incredible then you've got the uh cc
sarah michelle gellar in the sorority
house which is a kind of nice nod to
the opening scene of scream and does it
i think pretty effectively as a sort of
homage and similar kind of sequence and
then they kill off randy to give us the
big shock death in a really fun daylight
scenario i'm also i think screen 2 is by
far the gayest i think it gave the hell
out of me and i love it for it because
the hair improves incredibly you've got
timothy oliphant and jerry o'connell
just giving me those vibes all
throughout the film you've got theater
class you've got dramatic theater class
with like uh you know
the scene where
the weird trojan sort of
situation but it's very hyped up and
very uh you know and then you've got um
laurie metcalf as the most ridiculous
over-the-top villain in maybe horror
history since michael's mother since
jason's mother in uh debbie's salt so i
think it really lays it on um so it's my
favorite but i will say on the screen
the original screen is definitely the
reason i'm in my job like it's the thing
that ignited my passion for movies i saw
that in a cinema
when i was 12 years old with my friend
uh my brother who's a bit older than me
had come back from the movies two days
before and said you need to see this
movie it's terrifying and be there for
the opening scene and my friends and i
convinced his mother not to go but to go
with us to the line and convince some
guy in line to pretend he was our uncle
so that we could get in because it was
rated m a 15 plus which is an australian
rating where you have to be 15 or have a
guardian and we got in a movie
traumatized and delighted me and i was
on a path ever since then
that led me down the movie passion lane
but also the rotten tomatoes so
uh i have a bit big space in my heart
for number one but it's the one i want
to just watch when i'm two two bottles
of wine
uh two glasses of wine in on a thursday
get that comfort food uh it's always
gonna be oh and the scene in the film
school i cannot when she's sort of yeah
the soundproof booth with dewey i just
there's so many great sequences yeah the
first screen that's like any high school
kid should be able to relate to some
character in there and scream two is
more for the theater kids where you get
to celebrate all the sets and stuff like
that and you bring up a bottle or maybe
a glass of wine jacqueline i never had
anybody stand in line for me to buy a
ticket at a movie theater we were too
busy tracking down randos in the parking
lot of the grocery store to go buy us
beer that was
that was the main thing that we needed
from adults at that time it wasn't
buying a movie ticket i also think in
williamsburg virginia i bought a ticket
to knight reynolds street six when i was
12 years old they did not bat an eye and
so i think they were just a little more
forgiving in the woods where i grew up
and you got to see all the scream at
some point in your life which one stands
out as the goat uh scream three just
kidding no um
like because i feel like we all talked
about it i saw all of these except for
scream four in the theater this is
what's weird
on its face screen 2 should be my
favorite and in ways it is because it
has some of my favorite scenes i can't
believe i'm going to be the first one to
mention jerry o'connell standing on a on
a freaking
cafeteria table singing david partridge
i think i love you
which was given us courtesy of david
cassidy like come on come on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like that is probably one of the great
spontaneous song scenes and i think
heath ledger robbed it for every inch it
was worth and 10 things i hate about you
um but anyway like i love that movie but
the reasons why i hate it is because of
the randy dying scene and because
because i literally was like i cannot
believe they're killing him like i know
it's brilliant but like i have there's
too much emotion attached to the people
they killed in this movie when they
killed him and when she didn't believe
jerry o'connell was not the killer i was
just like i was so mad at her i think i
was mad at nev campbell for like a good
decade after that
like easily a good decade after that i
was so over her like i just ugh i
couldn't deal with her i have a question
about um
uh
sororities and fraternities because we
in australia don't really have these uh
i grew up in australia um and so our
education about this comes from movies
and so i watch scream too and think is
this what college is like in america
sounds the murders and i'm curious is
this giving your greek letters which
happens in the film jerry o'connell's
character controversially gives his
letters from his fraternity and the
necklace to sydney prescott much to
mickey slash timothy uh like warnings
that you shouldn't do that um is that a
thing that happens is that like a show
of love to give your letters to someone
i don't know
yeah
it's like in high school when he did the
class ring if you were in a fraternity
you might
give your letter it depends on college
by college i was not in a fraternity it
was not really
needed to get into the fraternity
parties at wake forest and so i'm like
well i can just go to every fraternity
part instead of just one that sounds
like more boost for me and so you just
kind of bounce around but they also have
these formals where you get to invite
someone that you are fancy on and that's
kind of like a big deal in there and so
it's pretty accurate and and then you
the way that fraternities are portrayed
in movies if you go back to something
like animal house it's not quite that
dramatic and it's not obviously that
much debauchery going on but there's the
potential for it and then it also is a
perfect setting to have a murder mystery
that we have to solve and
so if you have that if you have
something like happy death day
there's a lot of fun to be had on
college campuses as long as it's a
fictional murder that we have this and
just one last scream to thing like we
can't get off screen too without
acknowledging the brilliance of porsche
de rossi and rebecca gayhart who have
this like three lines in the movie but
kind of get away with it as these two
sorority girls um yeah incredible hi no
i really mean that
hi sydney
hey this must be flat out hell for you
how are you holding up i managed
it's really weird isn't it to think this
fuss is all because of you
i mean not directly but in some six
degrees of kevin bacon way yeah
now um
hallie are you gonna bring your friend
to our little martini mixer tonight
i have a lot of work we'll be there oh
good because sid we have our eyes on you
you hang in there and if there is
anything we can do the delta lambdas are
very sensitive to your plate yeah
bye
bye
that's the fun that i love about scream
though too is is because the movie
franchise kicks off with drew barrymore
and you see drew barrymore at that time
and you're like oh okay i guess this is
the star of the movie and then she dies
and it's like it's just such a great
announcement that this
film and this franchise are going to
take you in twists and turns that you're
not expecting so just hold on for dear
life because leading up to that you
would think oh wait okay this is clearly
the lead of the movie and the way that
that first phone it's one of the great
scenes in movie history it's one of the
great opening scenes not just in horror
movies in any genre because it so locks
you into the tone and it is legit
terrifying but i also loved it because
that's probably the impetus for my movie
trivia brain being like oh movie trivia
might be able to save your life
literally my question to you is if she
gets these movies correct if she gets
these trivia nuggets correct do they
spare her i still don't think so you
like scary movies uh-huh
what's your favorite scary movie uh i
don't know
you have to have a favorite what comes
to mind
um
halloween you know the one with the guy
in the white mask who walks around and
stalks babysitters
what's yours
yes
um
nightmare down the street is that the
one where the guy had knives for fingers
yeah freddy krueger freddy that's right
i like that movie it was scary wow well
the first one was but the rest sucked
scream 4 kind of answers that question
mark because kirby who's played by
hayden panettiere
is getting this is put in the same
situation with uh the the culkin kit uh
boys forget which one rory here it is
is it here it's the one who's not in
succession oh rory yeah rory who sat on
the who sat on the chair outside by the
pool like steve in the original opening
scene and kirby gets the answers right i
think doesn't she from memory and then
she goes out and they open the door and
well i mean i guess spoiler alert uh
rory culkin is one of the killers um
proceeds to stab her but that opening
scene i think was game-changing and
you know inspired by a stranger calls
and did just such interesting things and
i think terrorized people and they had
to sort of one-up it or attempt to
one-up it um
every film after that uh
did you i mean
is that your favorite scene in the
franchise it's it's tough but i'm also i
don't know how you feel about this
jacqueline i feel like jamie kennedy is
so great as randy when he's describing
the rules to us so i am thrilled that he
was left alive and screamed too long
enough to give us the sequel rules but
him in the video store i mean again as
as somebody in high school that's that's
what you aspire to at least for me
that's that was the goal in life was to
just get to be the authoritative voice
at your local video store and he
certainly was that so when he's breaking
down the rules it's like he's
we're stumbling around in this labyrinth
and we meet some randy
some old man who gives us this treasure
map that we trust and that kind of gets
us to the castle so i just i love that
we have that that road map to go by but
we're also going to break some of those
rules with a wink and a knot yeah i will
say what's interesting is every dude who
was that guy in their town whether it be
a huge city or a small city they all
think that they're quentin tarantino
who's probably the most famous all
knowledgeable
movie store guy
who then happened to make like genre
defying muse uh entertainment that like
you know really changed the way we look
at cinema but most of them
are randy and like there's just as many
people that are just sick of his crap if
you know what i mean like like it's just
for as much as i loved him for being
accused of being a know-it-all kid i get
why some people are like stab him
quickly because i was not i was in the
minority some people were like yes kill
him they did not like jamie kennedy i
think
and they just like did not like
necessarily him as that character and so
they were all about
him meeting a horrible
truck in a van they killed him in a van
like i still cannot get over how awful
that is he deserves so much better the
kids boombox come around the corner just
to cover it up
which is amazing
he just deserves so much better i'm
still like what a great kill i mean
isn't that what you want in these movies
like you want to go off with a bang you
have me that's how you want it the third
act like let him be the guy that like
shows up and it's like oh i think i've
saved you i'm gonna make it to the end
and then they kill him like that's a
real way to do that
and then he sort of comes out of the
granny later every time and he's like
yeah
he's like the internet there's like a
more of a limp the next time oh my god
what is the best kill
is is it is it the heartbreak that
jaclyn suffered at the hands of randy's
demise what is your favorite kill
in the history of the scream franchise i
don't want to be hacky and take drew
barrymore but it's so good and shocking
but as i referenced tatum in the garage
door is pretty inventive and that that
feels like it's just wes craven that
feels like when he was going to set that
day he just had a a song in his heart
and a giddy up in his step couldn't wait
to shoot that and a very cold fan yeah
yeah
people know
you get older biology takes over
there's a lot of cold air going on rose
mcgowan shirt in that scene and i don't
think it was necessarily needed but it
was the kill that i liked jaclyn
joel do you have a a kill that stands
out that gets you out of bed in the
morning i think you know i would also
say if we're taking barrymore off the
table which i think we should because i
think it's the one that's like the first
round the fantasy draft everybody's
gonna take that one yeah i would say
then it goes to jada but the other one i
do want to shout out is the uh sorority
girl cc uh sarah michelle geller in
the big store empty sorority house
because she's sober sister which i guess
i'll ask offline if that's another thing
that they do in these sororities it is
um okay she said her sister and so she
gets the kind of the phone call and i
really like that because i felt it just
gave us that opening scene of scream
original screen vibes but also because
wes craven is just can direct you know
not with his eyes closed because we
maybe he directed cursed and with his
eyes but um he can just direct these
movies like nobody's business and the
framing and sort of build up in that
scene and just the sort of way that he
allows ghost space to slip in behind her
and sort of has us constantly on edge
about what's going to be coming in and
out of the frame and the writing of that
scene is actually really good as well um
you know the girl upstairs the ted uh
and then ultimately a sort of iconic
finale to that to that scene where she
gets thrown off um the balcony in a shot
that goes on way too long for the height
of that balcony um i'm not sure what the
temperature was like on set that day but
she was wearing sort of a ribbed
cardigan so maybe we wouldn't know i
shouldn't say that's pretty disgusting
but it was a great um it was a great uh
great kill for me the casting throughout
all these movies is really impressive
because you you brought up obviously you
have nev campbell as our as our quote
final girl sydney prescott and she's
just got such the right balance of
innocence and toughness because she's
been through stuff that no high schooler
should have to go through and she really
wears that on her sleeve throughout
these movies i also think david arquette
is ingenious casting as a young cop is
trying to still prove himself who is
still
a dope but also really wants to be a man
and and you realize that being a man is
more than just having a mustache and
a bad hedge but scout out
scout out scout out to skate i mean
he's great he is exactly who i want her
boyfriend who turns out to be the killer
to look like him and matthew willard
together it's just you have so much gold
in that initial cast rose mcgowan though
like talking about casting rose mcgowan
in that original yeah original screen as
tatum is so good
uh like lightning in a bottle um
and then i think i think screen four is
actually pretty well cast if you think
about uh hayden penatierre as uh kirby
who sort of comes in as like a complete
breath of fresh air and i should note
dies in a way quote unquote dies in a
way that she may not be dead who knows
because we don't see the sort of full
death scene so could she be back for
number four five five which is actually
not called screen five we what's the
screen screen screen
and then parentheses 20 22. um but the
other one i want to shout out is casting
is molly shelton as deputy judy in
scream four so she's the deputy to dewey
when he's and she's sort of flirting
with him and courtney cox's gay
awareness feels threatened and she
brings him lemon squares and she's
actually she survived and she's now sort
of melding into the fore because she's
going to be in screen 2022 as well and
she's really fun
wait a minute i also just want to add um
they made gomer pyle get in a horror
movie which i think like in itself like
if they're like i know dewey's had his
day but just the fact that they put
gomer pyle in a horror movie and let
that play out over the course of four
movies now five
very interesting henry winkler as well
let's having yes who who's never out of
fashion um yeah
really was great as the principal in the
boat and i think in terms of like a
quick kill uh that's a great fun little
it's a sneaky good kill in in the first
movie when the principal eats it because
he's looking in the mirror and
especially at that time i i think we're
all ready for him to do a fonz moment
some sort of reference to fonts he's
checking his hair and he gets murdered
instead the fonz he jumped a shark
but he's now fallen yeah also uncredited
uh henry winkler was not in the credits
for that movie um and i forget what
that's no monster but there was like
somebody famous cameos that also like
because they didn't want them to be on
their imdb or like whatever they never
put their name into the actual credits
screen fans are going to kill me if i
get this wrong but i believe there is
also an uncredited cameo within that
scene a nugget within a nugget when he
is looking in the hallway uh to see if
there's someone out there there is a man
in a freddy krueger style sweater
mopping the floor and that is where's
craven himself i have i i think you were
correct on this sir i think great not to
to freddy krueger and and henry winkler
as the principal it just added up to
such a fun
mesh
of of cat and divergent personalities in
that first movie and it spawned this
franchise that we get now and so before
we transition into the behind-the-scenes
talk because i do want to get
everybody's take on what we're hoping to
expect from scream
2022
i do have a couple questions
about trivia i just want to test joel's
fandom jacqueline can play along too i
have a couple scream trivia questions
that
you should know but you might get a
couple of these jumbled so joel
jacqueline could be your lifeline
what is rule number one on randy's list
of rules for surviving a horror movie
oh lord i don't have sex
joel
gets the point that is correct do not
make love until after i'm sorry
you survived the movie i believe he has
sex so that counts um all right your uh
next question two remaining which
actress does sydney say would probably
play her in the movie version of her
life
story spelling
joel is two for two and he is cooking
now but now we come to the hardest
question instead yes
yes in the in the first scream how many
seconds delay
does the hidden camera in stu's house
have
oh and my brain is saying 30 or 10.
um
i can give you multiple choices this is
also an amazing kill uh just fyi kenny
the cameraman
oh it's a great kill yeah because
they're they're all at a party and
they're watching halloween and yes and
they set up a hidden camera
and then it's too the delay is too long
and then you know the poor
i'm gonna give me no i'm gonna say 30.
joel says 30.
this guy has seen these movies in
bunches that is correct joel mears
editor-in-chief of fraud tomatoes going
a perfect three for three on screen
trivia a couple of those could have
tripped him up but not joel so joel the
last word in this section is going to go
to you what is it about this scream
franchise that you just want to remind
everybody about why you love it so much
well i think
i think there's two things i think one
of the things is that it's the rare
horror franchise where you're actually
drawn to the survivors more than the
killer it's defined by
the core characters who are actually
unmasked in a sense so halloween you
know lori stewart is important of course
but michael myers jason freddy et cetera
are the faces of their
respective franchises and this is really
about dewey gayle and of course sydney
and they are the pulling thing and i
think there's such a great dynamic
between them i think sydney is just an
incredibly
powerful strong survivor that it's
something that i'm really drawn to i
know she pissed off uh dear jacqueline a
couple of times um but there is
something about nev campbell in this
role that i think is just
magnetic and defining and iconic and i
think there's a reason we continue to
follow her through it's also the only
franchise that we've seen so far five
movies now in a row where all of the
casters stay the same um i'm rambling
but also it's one of the rare branches
whether they actually cared about each
film right you know that first film
often they go with the sequel and gets
trash and they just bring in anyone but
they really made important decisions
creatively about who they brought in to
be steering this ship and we'll talk
about it in the next segment but yeah i
think you know obviously there's some
nostalgia and it hit me at the right
time in my life but
it's it's survival and care and craft
yeah that's the perfect way to sum it up
and so with that let's go to behind the
scenes
[Music]
the question is this do we consider
courtney cox and david arquette and nev
campbell to be the
dogs of this franchise in that they're
unkillable are they unkillable because
screen five comes out in january or
is one of them going to get off how can
this franchise continue to surprise us
by keeping all of them alive
jacqueline do you want to take this
everybody first i think you should go
first because in all honesty i'm kind of
like of two minds about it i'm like if
you kill them at this point i'm not
gonna be like
100 mad about it if you do it in a way
that feels like you're absolutely
passing the torch
you're very like robert downey jr and
end games how type way
but if you kill them and it just feels
like randy i'm gonna be mad yeah i think
i think i think one of them at least has
to die i'm gonna put it out there i
think
wow i mean five films in five of these
sort of scenarios it's it's getting a
little silly in some way could getting a
little bit silly you could say that
especially dewey because he almost dies
in basically every uh every every film
um i do think they've got to be
extraordinarily careful about how they
do it i think a sacrifice element is
probably the best way to do it we've
seen that in endgame um and maybe some
other movies that have been out this
month which i would talk about um but
there's uh you know it's a really
interesting thing
i think also this film is really being
set up as a passing of the torch in a
way that screen 4 was kind of set up but
then emma actually turned out to be the
killer so they couldn't go that part
that way this time they've got this
extraordinary young cast um
is it jessica barrera from um
in the heights uh along with uh mason
gooding jr uh all these sort of great
young actors who are there to really
take that torch um
i think i think they're setting it up
where at least one of them has to die
but i do think it's a tight line it's a
it's a tightrope high wire act uh that's
really good jenna ortega dylan minnette
uh melissa barrera in there here's the
thing though is that jacqueline i
again
we need to revisit this prediction
because now we need to see this movie
together opening night i feel like i
feel like they're all getting out i feel
like they're all getting out of this
thing scot-free i mean again i i feel
like if if joel is saying one of them's
got to die because it's cartoonish and
you're saying they've all got to make it
because they're the holy trinity i'm of
two minds about it i really am i'm like
make it work make the candle worth the
flame and i'll be i'll be with joel
but i'm telling you if it ends up being
weak sauce and i feel they're doing it
just to do it
basically i'm i'm being simplistic and
saying make it good which is like such
an easier thing than done but i will say
this i will be more forgiving of them
letting them live
and having it be weak sauce then i will
of them killing them and having it be
weak sauce yeah sure that's that that's
a fair point and so
you know i mean wes craven is the guy
responsible for not just this franchise
but so many of the great movies that we
got that are winked and knotted at by
this franchise originally was going to
be called scary movie and it spawned a
scary movie franchise so wes the the
west craven factor into this i feel like
wes craven is that rare hard director
that we all gave such credibility to
they could pull something like this off
and i love the the the joke in there
that tatum says like that wes carpenter
guy in the first one
giving a nod to john carpenter as well
and so wes craven and this is the first
one without him that's going to be an
interesting thing yeah
but it's a good team behind it it's um i
now forgetting their individual names
but they're collective known as radio
silence right um
and matt uh benton nelly open and tyler
gillett and i think
one of the reasons why they were able to
get somebody like nev campbell back is
because
according to an afghan they told they're
like hey you're the reason why
we love horror movies like you're the
reason why we do this and so we've seen
that in the past though if you're too
close to the source material you're too
much of a fan it's always sometimes it's
hard to do your own thing with it but
joel you have a lot of faith in what
they're going to do
yeah so for those who don't know they're
filmmakers who made ready or not um
which is a film that came out two years
ago
yeah where she was uh sort of brought to
a mansion to meet i think on a wedding
day and then there's a game for the
family plays that's a very very
effective horror comedy extremely well
received um and you can see tonal
similarities between
the the you can see why they were a good
fit and i actually did get to interview
nev campbell um last year for a film she
did um with alex wolff actually
jacqueline who was a guest on that
podcast
um
she said yeah she said they wrote her a
letter and they said all of that stuff
and they said that they really want to
honor wes they have so much respect for
him and his vision that that's what
that's what sort of got her to sign on
um which is exciting so nice i do have
faith in them they also contributed to a
anthology movie called southbound um
which is really really effective and
scary uh among that sort of like
multiple story horror thing um so
they've got the chops um i do have faith
and the cast i the cast is really good
the young cast i think is really
exciting as well okay well look again
whatever we're all doing in january
jacqueline i know your schedule gets
packed there you got to make a night for
us we all got to do this together i
think i can make time for that
we gotta get get perducy lucy there um
because she's gonna be terrified and
that's gonna be fun to watch lucy are
you signing up for our scream five
opening night
voyage
yes but you have to pay me
we'll pay you in popcorn and all the
soda you can drink i know our beloved
engineer christian rubicaba today brian
perez is going to want to go too it's
going to be it's going to be a fun all
right let's transition over to mailbag
[Music]
we love all of the members of our
ketchup crew who are listening today
they're certified fresh in our hearts
and this one comes from ellen musket who
wrote us at rt is wrong at rotten
rottentomatoes.com you all can follow
ellen's lead and send us an email with
your thoughts what movies you want us to
talk about coming up soon and ellen
writes hello mark jacqueline and to the
rest of the team in the ketchup crew
hillary here running from toronto right
at the beginning of tiff i just finished
listening to mark's fantastic discussion
with chance the rapper while washing the
dishes that see we help you be
productive with the household chores
clean up happens late when you've got
two toddlers i want to advocate for a
movie that i believe is shockingly
underrated vin diesel's passion project
2004's rolican gothic space epic the
chronicles of riddick its predecessor
the more modest aliens knock off pitch
black got a reasonable 60
on the tomato meter so it's tied with
screen four but chronicles of freddick
which takes much bigger swings and
stacks the deck with excellent classical
actors doing top-notch work judy dench
comb fior carl urban bandy newton and a
return visit from they live's keith
david but it only managed a rotten 29
percent thanks and happy arguing that is
from
ellen in toronto
canada thank you so much and give our
best to the two little ones
dad um the chronicles of riddick joel
you are the editor-in-chief of rotten
tomatoes i know you don't influence the
tomato meter but 29
you got some folks north of the wall not
happy about that yeah there might be
something a little strong in her
dishwashing detergent i think
so the whole fumes getting to lovely
elin's mind no look we all have our
films that we go to bat for i will to
this day uh die on the hill that is
scream three um so
all i'll say is yeah sure it's worthy of
discussion i guess um
the only thing i actually thought i i
remember seeing that film and not
thinking a lot of it not thinking it was
a disaster uh so i could revisit it and
give you an opinion but i did remember
judy dench that's i was like this is the
movie with judy dench and vin diesel
right and
that alone i think maybe deserves a 50.
just just that in the credits
now we get to see him and helen mirren
driving speeding all over the place
together uh joel mears the
editor-in-chief of rotten tomatoes it's
always a pleasure when you stop by
thank you so much for your insight for
your bravery in standing scream three i
am so looking forward to seeing what our
loyal listeners have to say about that i
think i think they're gonna agree with
you for the most part i think that a lot
of people feel like this movie got a
little bit shafted
yeah totally um it's scary it's funny
it's a good time and it's got some depth
also the best cameo in the entire
franchise carrie fisher in the archives
look after him not gonna argue with that
logic at all so i you always ask the
guests at this point what what are you
working on what upcoming projects do you
have i know you got a book coming out
soon right
we do i could reach but i can't i should
i i was supposed to actually but yes we
do we've got a book coming out uh
november nine uh binge uh
my god the ultimate binge guide uh 296
tv shows that changed the way we watch
television so get that into you it's a
it's a great book um jacqueline
contributed uh i contributed and vote
for it plus a bunch of other people it's
it's it's fantastic and it's it's hard
it's really beautiful i'm really excited
about how beautiful it is you're going
to want to give this to people
okay i'm excited to check it out and i
think it's going to make the christmas
gift of this year but again we're not at
christmas for it halloween so joel do
you have any fun recommendations in the
way of movies that the kids should check
out during the spooky time of year
always um i watch trick or treat every
halloween at least once um which is the
brilliant anthology uh young pumpkin kid
uh it's it's such a joy um
and i'll give some shout outs to some
good old fashioned australian horror uh
i would say watch rogue uh which is a
great crocodile movie maybe not as good
as the alligator beauty crawl but
certainly very very fun oh i love crawl
so much then yeah we could talk about
alejandra well we were talking offline
earlier but um and then i would say the
loved ones uh which is a sort of really
really interesting movie about a young
woman who kidnaps a boy uh prior to
their prom slash what we call an
australian formal and then kind of
tortures him and it's very violent and
scary and good and i believe it's
certified fresh at 90 something
ridiculous on the tomato meter um so
that's the loved ones uh from about 2000
and somewhere between 2009 and 2011. oh
dear why would you why would you kidnap
why would you invite more teens into
your life than is is already necessary
that's the question for another day
after seeing that movie uh jacqueline i
don't think that we're quite done with
the horror movie season just yet here at
the show remind you you can email us
anytime rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com subscribe rate review
whatever platform you choose to listen
to this podcast we thank you for your
support and make sure you do whatever
that platform encourages you to do to
get this rated positively because you
all been so good at it so let's keep up
the good work thanks to joel mears the
editor-in-chief of rotten tomatoes make
sure y'all check out the ultimate binge
guide when it is released sometime in
the next few weeks and or month you can
follow him on twitter he's a great
follow and he occasionally retweets when
i post stand updates which you can get
tickets for stanford mark ellis dot live
jacqueline coley my team co-host lucy
bruckner producee lucy christian
rubicaba our great engineer for the
whole team here at rotten tomatoes and
for all of those who fell during the
scream franchise we send our best wishes
and thanks for listening we'll see you
next time
at rotten tomatoes as well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you